there's your precious toilet summer I'm
not going to the bathroom on a fire
hydrant
high maintenance you're joking right me
I told you to go before we left
just find a reality with the normal
toilet I'll hold it till we get back to
earth this is why I put a catheter in me
[Music]
Rick Rick you gotta come with me you
gotta come quick to the hospital Rick to
the hospital what are you talking about
Morty I'm trying to watch my TV show
here what are you talking about go to
the hospital more you come with me Rick
please please Rick because Jessica got
hit by a car Rick she's in the hospital
right now it's not looking so good Rick
it's not looking so good calm down
moaning just calm down and relax
can it wait till after family matters is
over Winslow's matters is about to scold
his daughter Laura matters over some
sort of thing I'm really engaged with
Rick forget about all that show we gotta
go to the hospital Rick Connor this is
some serious stuff you gotta help me be
better help me you gotta use your
science and hell you gotta help Jessica
she's she's the woman of my dreams she's
the woman of my dreams and she's about
to die Rick she's about to die
you could have helped me Rick you gotta
come to the hospital Rick all right all
right Morty fine fine fine Jesus Christ
all right let's go Morty let's go to
hospital all right Rick there she is
she's right there Rick you gotta do
something Rick you got a do sorry Morty
shut the mouth up and let me figure
something out here we see what we do
here all right I got an idea Morty here
put this on put this put this talky
advice on head device thing on all right
Rick I'm putting it on okay now here I'm
gonna put mine on
now I'm gonna shrink you down and I'm
gonna inject you into her body geez Rick
you're gonna put me inside of her body's
trick me down I mean you know I'm I
don't know if I'm equipped for that
right Morty what you want me to do we're
either gonna do this one way or we're
not gonna do it at all I'm gonna go back
and watch Family Matters like I was
doing before you bothered me right all
right all right Rick all right fine
you know you've been a real son of a
[ __ ] Rick you know you're being a real
you really being a real piece of garbage
right now Rick you know you're being a
real thrill jerk right now Rick just
shrink me down and put me in her and
tell me what to do right Morty you know
here we go go to shrink you down all
right Morty nah man inject you into her
arm here all right there you go morning
Rick I can hear you it's crazy in here
Rick it's crazy in here there's all
kinds of things floating around
Morty I bet you there's a lot of whole
kinds of things floating around hey what
do you know Morty there's a TV set in
here I wonder if family matters is still
armed oh it is it's still on Morty
I think they're in the third act
floating around in Jessica's bloodstream
you're gonna watch TV please there's a
giant white thing floating towards me
yeah I'm only relaxed I'll tell you what
to do
so float upstream a little bit and tell
me when you get to the heart valve
oh jeez hey you know Morty you know it's
kind of strange but family matters was
actually a spinoff of the movie die hard
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
new Rick and Morty season four to talk
about a special deleted scene in a
couple of new versions of Rick and Morty
that they revealed because of what's
going on in New York Comic Con next week
so we'll break it all down I'll be doing
Rick and Morty episodes and easter-egg
videos all season long so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I also do
merch giveaways every week I'll explain
at the end of the video the footage
starts with them taking summer to
another reality because she just needs
to find a toilet
I guess they came from a reality where
there is no bathrooms but the first one
they go to looks like the reality that
snuffles took all the intelligent dogs
too at the end of lawnmower dog in
season 1 episode 2 they just packed up
and took off to another reality to form
their own society that's why everything
in here is dog themed some of it seems
kind of nostalgic too and the dog behind
them is walking on two legs washing its
hands in the sink and looking at them
like she's scandalized that they just
appeared out of nowhere in the women's
bathroom so even though Rick is kind of
playing a joke on summer here he was
nice enough to take her to a woman's
room I guess this wall art is meant to
be a classic like this is what our
culture used to be we used to sniff each
others butts like this all the time it
is a little bit weird that they're still
using fire hydrants instead of using
traditional toilets that take their
business away but maybe there's some
complicated trapdoor system as part of
these if they are super smart they
probably found a way to do it the next
joke being that Rick takes her to
another reality that's purely based on
toilet culture this is kind of another
continuation of the joke in close
encounters of the Rick kind where
they're running through dimensions to
escape the Citadel of Rick's and they
run through one of the dimensions that's
a bunch of intelligent chairs with
humans as the furniture this time is
toilets that rule this culture but
humans are still somehow the furniture
because you output these human design
toilets they're all staring straight
ahead they don't
blink so it's hard to tell if these
humans are intelligent they have a
condom dispenser on the wall but because
they're for intelligent toilets they're
called [ __ ] Odom's as in commode the news
board on the wall is called the daily
clog the motivational poster on the wall
is a reference to tourists never being
clogged always running there's a baby
changing station but as for changing
baby bowls as in toilets for babies
there's old timing art of a clown toilet
from the depression on the wall instead
of traditional toilet paper they have
little hands on sticks for cleaning
themselves and plungers for the look of
this toilet with the long eyelashes it
also seems like this is meant to be a
woman's toilet room for women toilets
weird that the versions of these toilets
and sinks are dudes then if this is
meant to be a woman's room the final
joke being that he takes them to the
bathroom what looks like this hellscape
dimension where the women in the
background kind of looked like Cenobites
from the Hellraiser movies the red
coloration in the rock formations also
kind of makes it seem like this bathroom
is inside a similar reality when they
fought World ender with of indicators
during season 3 episode 4 and Rickon the
saw treatment the real joke here though
is that they're at the worst possible
reality you could go to but silver
lining they almost use the exact same
style of normal toilets that Rick Marty
and summer are used to like here here's
your normal toilet it just happens to be
in the worst possible reality of course
summer freaks out wants to hold it and
we learned that apparently Rick put a
catheter in c-137 Morty to prevent him
from having to take time away from
adventures to go to the bathroom I
wouldn't totally take that as canon
though the fact that Morty is walking
around with the catheter in him this
whole time because we did see more to
use a bathroom in their house the
beginning of pickle Rick in season 3
episode 3 which he wouldn't need to do
if he still had the catheter even if it
is just a one-off joke it seems kind of
weird that he would be so proud of Rick
putting a catheter in him the deleted
scene is actually a super deep cut from
Justin roiland
early early work on the show when he was
trying to get it going at Adult Swim it
was one of his auditions to prove to
them that he could make the show in it
Morty is desperately trying to get Rick
to help him save Jessica's life because
she was hit by a random car and taken to
the emergency room but Rick doesn't want
anything to do with it because he's
watching the 90s sitcom Family Matters
except what they're doing with the show
is that they're doing the thing where
they sometimes explain a real-life TV
show but do it in a non
way is if the writers are acting like
they purposefully don't know what the
show is actually about that they're
parroting Winslow matters and his
daughter Laura matters in one of the
earlier seasons they did a game of
Thrones parody but they called it tiny
people and it was all the main
characters from Game of Thrones in the
iron throne room all short in Tyrion
Lannister standing in the middle drawer
tall just and run explain that that's
part of the bit is that they explain it
in a nonsense way as if they don't
actually watch the show but most of them
do actually watch these shows that they
parody the deleted scene is also meant
to give you an early concept for the
relationship dynamic between Rick and
Morty where Rick and barely be bothered
to help party but reluctantly agrees to
do so because despite what he says in
his protest he actually does genuinely
care about Morty you can see that they
polished the animation on this a lot by
the time this went to series because
neither of them are drawn to their
official character models and the living
room configuration is vastly different
you also notice that there's a special
transition between scenes they don't
actually do that in Rick and Morty
episodes then Rick shrinks Morty down
and sends him into Jessica's bloodstream
an idea that they would later replicate
during anatomy Park in season 1 episode
3 when Rick shrunk Morty down and they
did their Jurassic Park parody then Rick
tries to sell Morty on the concept that
Family Matters is actually a die hard
spin-off because the same actor appeared
in both projects Reginald veljohnson
all while Morty seems like he's being
consumed alive by an intelligent white
blood cell moving into more season 4
news though if you're going to New York
comic-con in the next week as I'm
posting this video apparently they're
gonna be selling new Rick and Morty
season 4 toys but it's shrimp Rick and
shrimp Morty so apparently we're gonna
see these two versions of the characters
during season four either Rick and c-137
Morty crossed paths with them in an
episode or either Citadel or they
themselves are turned into shrimps for
some reason also recently one of the
writers on the show Jeff flub knows just
finished his work on season four we
posted all these pictures of his scripts
that he had done he did season 4 episode
1 episode 6 episode 7 episode 8 and
apparently season 5 episode 1 someone on
reddit actually tried to scan and invert
the scripts to read the text beneath the
pages but they were only able to
discover that episodes 8 title seems to
be my cancelled vacation which doesn't
Sal
a typical Rick and Morty episode title
so they might actually change that
before this episode airs season four is
confirmed to be 10 episodes and for
right now it seems like Adult Swim is
just gonna air 10 episodes per season
every year which works out to ten total
seasons of Rick and Morty that doesn't
mean that they're gonna cancel the show
after 10 seasons it just means that they
have to renew their contract again after
that and Dan Harmon and Justin run did
say that they would continue making the
show as long as they possibly could
right now it seems like Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 1 is gonna officially
premiere November 17th on that Sunday
night because Adult Swim is doing a big
festival on the 15th and 16th right
before that where they'll screen the
first episode early like I said I'll be
doing Easter egg videos episode videos
all season long if you have any bonus
videos that you really want me to make
or theories you want me to do videos
about just let me know in the comments
below I will be doing merch giveaways
and all my Rick and Morty videos all you
have to do to enter those is just be a
subscriber and leave your best Rick &
Morty season 4 Theory congratulations
Benjamin Wayman you're the giveaway
winner from my last Rick and Morty video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my last Rick
and Morty season for Thanksgiving
trailer and click here to learn how
Marvel just got spider-man back in the
MCU from Sony thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]